[Music]
all right Nintendo I know you have more
breath of the wild 2news somewhere come
on you can upload it any second now
Nintendo you're getting on my nerves
Nintendo come on I need more news
Nintendo please Nintendo duh whatever
well while we're waiting on Nintendo to
give us something anything new on breath
of the well to which let's face it could
take a really really long time or you
know they could surprise us and hit us
with an unannounced Nintendo Direct and
drop a breath of the wild to trailer at
the end like they're so good at doing ha
but alas until that happens I suppose
we're free to wonder about other aspects
of Zelda games in the meantime which is
why today I've compiled my own list of
the top 5 best vehicles link gets to use
across the Zelda franchise but first a
little disclaimer what's up guys mask
Nintendo Vanda here and thanks for
joining me today I wanted to apologize
real quick because I may have been a bit
misleading with this video as in I may
have not really used the textbook
definition of what a vehicle is and by I
may not have used it I mean I really
didn't use it according to our BFF the
merriam-webster dictionary which of
course every good honest English speaker
has memorized a vehicle is quote a means
of carrying or transporting something
end quote I'm gonna go with that
definition alone and completely ignore
the fact that it says such as a motor
vehicle or piece of mechanized equipment
now what I mean by quote unquote vehicle
in the Zelda universe is actually pretty
broad it could be as simple as a tool or
gadget or it could be an actual
motorized mechanical thing but the point
is it has to enhance links movement in
positive way and we'll be judging these
vehicles based on their ease of use
amount link has to use them you know
stuff like that if you do happen to
enjoy this video please consider liking
and subscribing to stick around
let us endure this long blistering wait
until more breath of the wild two news
together and allow me to entertain you
along the journey alright that's enough
of that once again thanks for being here
and watching and without further ado on
to the content starting off the list for
entry number five we have links longshot
from ocarina of time I suppose you could
be more general and say links hookshot
for number five which has been featured
in several Zelda games both 3d and 2d
but I specifically chose the long shot
from ocarina of time because well it's
just essentially a better hook shot and
we all know the hook shot is so much
better than its ugly cousin the claw
shot but anyway moving around in ocarina
of time becomes so much easier once you
get your hands on this little precious
item this handheld device shoots a hook
out of one end which in reality more
resembles a spear head than a hook which
is attached to a long chain and lodged
itself into a target or compatible
surface when it gets caught on a surface
or a target it will then retract back
into its handle pulling both ends
together which normally means moving
link through the air over gaps and
whatnot like Superman actually no I take
that bat like that it works on hook shot
targets and also any wooden surface
throughout the game that's right you can
use it on trees treasure chests or even
this roof here to get out of jail free
you can even use it as a weapon of sorts
that will stun enemies and it'll pull
items towards you so you don't have to
run and get them yourself so really
being a vehicle is only one aspect of
this wonderful little gadget coming in
at number five number four brings us the
wonderful Pegasus boots from a Link to
the Past I mean they're not only
featured in a Link to the Past but
that's the most known iteration of them
arguably speaking these boots completely
change the entire way you travel in
every game it's in prior to the most
recent to 3d Zelda games Skerritt sword
and breath of the wild our boy link here
had no stamina with which to sprint
across highway but he
need it see back in the day and a Link
to the Past and others link just put on
these here Pegasus boots and honky Tonk
the little boot dance in a way he went
running like the wind bullseye now it
wasn't until four swords that he was
able to actually move directions while
running with the boots on but even if
you were to slam into a wall or other
surface that stops your movement
momentarily the fact that you could run
with the spirit of Apollo himself is
more than worth it the boots are needed
throughout various different puzzles in
the games and are even required to beat
bosses sometimes but the best part about
is the fact that link holds his sword
out in front of him while sprinting
that's right any enemies in the way not
anymore now number three is arguably the
most unique vehicle on this list and
guess what it's actually a vehicle like
an actual mechanized construct see don't
give up on me I'll make sense eventually
anyway number three is the spinner from
Twilight Princess now not only is it the
most unique entry on this list because
it's like a top that spins itself but
it's also the friggin coolest I mean who
hasn't imagined link on a skateboard
just ripping up the sidewalk grinding on
all the rails well now you don't have to
imagine because this is basically the
same thing see he can even jump like a
real skateboard person does it's so
basically you get the spinner in the
arbiters grounds dungeon and you can use
it to attach yourself to Rails and
totally grind alongside them and jump in
between them and well well actually
that's about it I mean it does damage
enemies when you jump so that's cool
and you don't sink in the quicksand on
the spinner but it does run out of
spinach juice pretty quickly okay so it
isn't actually very useful and there are
no rails around but there are some rails
there outside of arbiters grounds that
the spinner is used for you know some
secret areas and whatnot so it's not
like this is the only place you'll use
it but yeah the spinner is number three
because it's friggin cool okay it's my
list guy next up for number two we're
back to being really really useful but
also back to not being a real
vehicle anyway the zora armour from
Twilight Princess takes the cake here
now underwater exploration has been a
staple in the Zelda series since the
days of a Link to the Past
ever since link was first able to swim
underwater and fight enemies and solve
puzzles and dungeons underwater movement
has just been getting better with the
iron boots being introduced in ocarina
of time which when paired with the
Sora's tunic allowed link to freely move
around on the ground under water and the
Zora mask in Majora's Mask which
transforms link into a full-on Zora able
to swim freely through the water and rip
it up on the guitar but that's besides
the point that's possessed it got even
better er in Twilight Princess when it
combined the best of both worlds and
gave Link the Zora armor which granted
water breathing for the hero of Twilight
and allowed him to swim freely under the
water you can even pair it with the Iron
Boots for unlimited underwater summer
fun there are loads of places to use
this armor in game so it is a must-have
if you're really wanting to explore the
world of Hyrule
it also looks oddly stylish for its
fishy design okay guys he's still there
he's still breathing
okay cool just got a check before we hit
the number one best vehicle across the
entire Zelda franchise I had a quick
honourable mention the bunny hat or
whatever it's called from majora's mask
yes it is incredibly useful and doesn't
have any charge up or cool down or any
consequence at all for wearing it but
the Pegasus boots actually beat this one
for the spot at number four because I
don't know the bunny hat isn't that fun
to use I mean come on how do you beat
link doing a little shim sham and
dead-on sprinting across the screen with
a sword out I mean you mean to tell me
that this hat that just makes you quick
across the board is more fun to use it
may be more useful but is it more fun or
maybe I just have a problem I don't know
next up at number one is the one and
only you guessed it
motorcycle for breath of the wild whoa
wait wait it's not actually called a
motorcycle it's it's the master cycle
zero which is ironic because I'm not
sure what's supposed to be zero about it
it definitely consumes fuel to move a
lot of it it would be nice if it ran off
of links I don't know life essence orb
something a little less creepy like
whatever godlike batteries the sheikah
installed in the guardians and divine
beasts that allows them to function
without any other known power source
anyway the master cycle is super useful
because one it enhances the ground
movement speed greatly and two can warp
to wherever link currently is by use of
is all-powerful sheikah tablets well not
anywhere I mean for some reason it
doesn't work in the desert but I digress
now I know what you're thinking why not
imp onna or any other horse you can tame
in breadth of the wild some of them
sprint faster than the master cycle and
you don't have to gas them up like you
do the cycle also if you put the sheikah
armor on the horse it can warp to where
link is as well
I see those points I see those points
and believe me it's actually a closer
competition than you think but what can
I say something about link riding a
motorcycle is just so so that was the
list guys what did you think do you have
a favorite quote unquote vehicle in
Zelda or even just a favorite gadget in
general let me know in the comments
below
once again huge huge thanks to my
patreon supporters and those in my
discord server who recently have been
there for me through a very tough time
in my life you know who you are
thank you so much also I have my first
fan animation and spoiler alert it is
super cute now I don't want to steal any
views from the artist so I'm gonna put a
link to it in the description below but
if you'd like to see it please check it
out and show the artist a little love
it's a short little video won't take up
much of your time and like I said it is
super cute stay tuned just a little bit
longer to the end of this video for an
easter egg of sorts and that's all I got
for you see you guys in the next video
have a great rest of your day
3
[Music]
hey there sorry I just got back from the
gym so I'm super disgusting but do you
want to meet the real best Zelda vehicle
prepare to meet opponent my opponent
there she would have been
see there she is oh gosh I gotta clean
see you in the next video buh-bye
[Music]